all right my friends let's take a tour
through the disaster porn that is the
George Santos Fiasco as many of you know
George Santos is the Republican
congressman who has lied about
everything he lied about his education
he lied about his employment history he
lied about being Jewish he lied about
being a volleyball star he lied about
when and how and how seriously he got
coveted and was hospitalized and tested
positive I don't know if any of those
things are even true at this point in
time and there are even more lies and
you know I tweeted about some of these
people thought I was kidding it's become
a meme to say Emmy Award winner George
Santos and people go yeah okay funny
Abby award he didn't really say that he
won an Emmy that I'm aware of and I
tweeted George Santos claimed that he
had two knee Replacements from being a
volleyball star and people thought it
was one of those jokes it's not he
really claimed this there is there is
now a lie upon lie George Santos falsely
claimed he was a volleyball star at
Baroque College in New York
he now has been caught on video claiming
that he was such a star that it led to
him messing up his knees and needing two
knee Replacements it doesn't appear to
be true this was on the Sid and friends
in the morning program back in 2020
listen to this this is unbelievable
George Santos running against Tom swazi
in a third congressional district coming
up next Tuesday hey you know it's funny
George you go right to the heart here of
me Sid and Bernie at the very end of
your biography it says in his spare time
right George Anthony enjoys volleyball
and Tennis let me tell you why that's
funny you're on this show Bernie's
daughter Melanie it's funny because
we're all liars as well was a star
volleyball player in college and my
daughter Ava as we speak is working on a
tennis scholarship when she goes to
college so now it's not enough that
they're all volleyball Stars even though
George Santos was not George Santos is
such a star that now he says he had two
knee Replacements it's it's amazing so
the two sports that you seem to enjoy on
the weekends are the same two sports our
two daughters excellent I daughters you
know it's funny I actually went to
school on a volleyball scholarship
I did yeah
um when I was in Baruch we were the
number one volleyball did you graduate
from there yeah so did I I did so did I
very that's a lie great school great
institution very beautiful but very good
very good professors who don't show
their bias which is which is very uh
interesting but that's a whole nother
conversation but it's funny that we went
to we went to to play against Harvard
Yale and we
I spiked four home runs and three
touchdowns and then my knees exploded
we were Champions across the entire
Northeast Corridor every school that
came up against us they were shaking at
the time and it's funny I was the
smallest guy in 962 we had on our block
is he six two I mean we that's probably
a lie right I don't know if he just he
lies we should fact check his height on
our on our ball on our block alone there
were six thousand six eight these guys
weren't jumping they were just
stretching their arms
we were we weren't Adam all of us should
have been playing basketball but we
chose volleyball because it was easier
that was a it was a great time I look I
sacrificed both my knees and got very
nice knee replacement uh knee
Replacements
playing volleyball that's how serious I
took the game guys I mean he actually
listen he had knee Replacements they
were just on other people's knees he
organized knee replacements for other
people give the guy a break he actually
had four knee Replacements on three
knees if you would believe it it's multi
just one of the young it's a record
actually for how young and the number of
knee Replacements he's had lying and
lying and lying this is a sick person
this is an illness but that doesn't mean
we excuse it right the fact that he
seems to have this inability to control
his lying doesn't mean we say so he
should get to stay in congress he should
resign the pressure is building and it
appears that he has even lied about his
name
there is something you use at home every
day that is significantly harming the
planet and it is your toilet paper 30
million trees are destroyed every year
for toilet paper in the U.S alone
deforestation is a contributor to
climate change and I think moving away
from tree based toilet paper is
something we can all do and that's why I
asked real paper to be our sponsor real
paper is a toilet paper made 100 from
bamboo stocks which grow forever so no
cutting down trees and all of real
papers packaging is plastic free think
of all those big plastic bags you've
thrown out over the years real paper is
a b Corp certified by the forest
Stewardship Council and real paper
plants one tree with every purchase you
make and the best part is you can do a
part to fight climate change without
making any sacrifice because real paper
is soft and fluffy and durable just like
traditional toilet paper you're used to
guys this is a no-brainer for anyone who
cares about the issue of deforestation
give real paper a try go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 30 off your first order plus
free shipping the link is down below